[Music]
all right let's go to brandon in
columbus ohio what's up brandon
hey dr john how are you doing i'm good
brother how are you i am doing really
well today
excellent man so what's up man how can i
help
uh yeah so i uh will
put a lot of moving pieces so i'll try
to keep this laser focused but
so grew up my mom was a pretty intense
alcoholic
and um she recently
about seven or eight years ago um got
sober
thankfully and was doing really well
and then just this year has kind of
relapsed and
some added medication addictions
and just some pretty crappy stuff and
then has been in and out of the hospital
a bunch
since january and uh there's a couple
like serotonin overdoses and
um certain stuff like that um she's
kind of had some suicidal language in
there
um and she's been a week in a
psychiatric hospital
um she's struggling huh yeah just
struggling so i'm just
i'm i'm like wondering um you know
half half what's my responsibility half
uh
like i just don't know what to do i feel
like she has no will
um and you know it's just just tough so
anything what's your relationship like
with her
not good yeah um it was
it wasn't good growing up uh well it was
awesome growing up until i
became the age where i was like oh not
everyone's mom
drinks this much so um and then
it got really bad and then she got sober
and we kind of reconciled and it got
better but
um the last few years hasn't been that
good at all
yeah dude i'm sorry man
that's all right thanks man how old are
you
i am 25.
man so you know this i'm just gonna say
it out loud
um there's not a lot of givens
in the world um not a lot of
should always bees but every little boy
you got brothers and sisters i have one
little
down syndrome brother okay
yeah that's even a whole other
complication but
every little boy one of the givens of
the universe should be
that you can count on your mom and that
you can count on your dad
and they didn't show up man i'm sorry
do you have a dad in the picture at all
i do
they've uh they've been divorced for
since i was in like seventh grade
um and he's he's in the picture he
you know cares for my my brother you
know here and there and
um you know he wants the same for my mom
as well even though they're
apart so so yeah sounds like your mom's
got a lot of
baggage and trauma of her own she's
still wrestling with huh
yeah yeah for sure okay yeah i uh
i feel like i've tried to have that
conversation with her and
you know intense psychotherapy and
yeah i don't know it just doesn't land
so there's not my experience has been
there's not a lot of conversation to be
had with addicts um
there is a lot of connection to be had
but there's not a lot
of oh okay does that make sense it's not
like they're missing a piece of
information
most of the true addicts like you're
talking about your mom who've been at it
a long long time they
they know more than anybody how awful
this is they know more than
anybody how badly they want to quit
um they know what this like you're
losing your family
they know right i don't know a lot of i
know a few but i don't know a lot of
addicts that can't see it
right um and so that makes those
conversations that makes those
learning opportunities hard um
here's the best thing the the couple
things i can give you it sounds like
your mom has crossed a new line
where now she's using pills and it's
almost as though she's practicing an
exit strategy
which often for addicts who've been at a
long time they just get exhausted
and i don't know that they want to kill
themselves as much as they want this
thing to stop
right and so suicide often isn't the
problem suicide becomes the solution
to an exhausted frustrating just getting
hounded and hounded by these ghosts of
addiction right
what ultimately did she say
made her contemplate suicide ended up in
a psych ward
yeah uh she was um
i was at work one day and around
lunchtime
she just i answered the phone and i
could immediately tell that she was
you know drunk and on other stuff and
just was like you know um
i don't think i can do this anymore you
know uh
your brother loves you you need to take
care of them
um all that stuff you know so she that
that's that's when those conversations
they don't scare me like in a like
horror movie kind of way but
that's somebody who's not just playing
around right
sure that's somebody's thinking it
through and they're making arrangements
and they're making a plan right um so
since she's been out has she been clean
since she'd been out of the psych ward
or she just go right back
she hasn't she it's nowhere near the way
she used to be but it's been like
uh you know i i might talk to her once a
week and
um from what i hear it seems like she's
maybe a couple weeks or a couple days of
the week she's
you know under something um i don't i'm
not sure it's every day but
definitely back at it since you've been
out yeah okay y'all live in the same
town
uh we live about 30 minutes apart okay
and then real quick tell me
what the situation is with your little
brother are you do you have custody of
him or does your dad have custody of him
what's the situation with him
yeah so he my mom actually lives with
her sister my aunt
um who's just spent her whole life
taking care of other people
and cares for my brother and along with
my dad
okay so sounds like a pretty
remarkable woman there huh oh yeah
incredible so there's a couple of
short-term and long-term things okay are
you a reader
i do i enjoy reading okay there's two
books i want you to read number one
is a book called in the realm of hungry
ghosts
and we'll link to it in the show notes
it's by gabor mate
it's a it's a new book on
it's not new but um it's one of the most
revelation revolutionary books on
addiction i've ever read
it's hard to read um but it is
remarkable the second book is a book i
read this year
that was just astounding and it's called
the unbroken brain
a revolutionary way of understanding
addiction
um and i'll mispronounce the author's
name but it's
my a m-i-a-i-salavitz
s-z-a-l-a-v-i-t-z and again we'll link
to that in the show notes as well
it really reframes addiction and
actually walks through the history of
addiction how
why how and why we started calling it a
disease
um and the medicalization of it and she
reframes it as
a learning disorder as a way a body
learns to cope
over time and when we think learning
disorder you think oh just stop or
it's not that easy um it's still super
complex but here's what's beautiful
um we solve diseases by isolating
the disease into a into an isolated room
and we give it medicine and we give it a
plan and by looking at it as
a learning dis as a learning disorder
really
it you reframe learning disorders
through active
intense connection right so here's the
deal
beating up an addict isn't helpful right
think of addiction as a connection
disorder it's somebody desperately
trying to connect and they can't for
whatever reason they are traumatized
as a kid and learn that relationships
will will abuse you
get you hurt get you killed then
relationships aren't safe and at the
same time a body has to have
relationships
and pills and alcohol can help sometimes
so beating up somebody yelling at them
trying to give them new information
sending them books that's
i've just never seen that be successful
an addict has to decide i'm done with
this and then they have to go get
with part of a group whether that's a a
whether that's a church whatever that
looks like
they have to get with a group of people
and learn how
to have relationship again learn how to
have safe vulnerable interactions again
that's why so many people find aaa
successful they get to practice
relationships together
practice vulnerability together that you
can't do when
other relationships are going to get you
hurt um some people don't like aaa
i just i think the idea of it is
remarkable so here's the things you can
do okay number one
is firm compassion i love you
but here's my boundaries right so she
can't show up at your house if she's
been drinking
if she calls you and she's super drunk
say hey mom i love you
um i told you i i i can't talk to you
when you're super drunk or you're super
high i love talking to you though
so tomorrow i'd love to get together and
talk to you okay so give me a call back
and gently hang up the phone right this
is you
compassionate and boundaries okay
the second thing is is getting on the
same page with everybody
when's the last time you went and had
just lunch or breakfast with um
your mom's sister the one who's taking
care of her your dad your little brother
have you ever just gone out and talked
to her i haven't okay
so you're 25 now and so i would tell you
stop looking at this as a little boy as
a teenager start looking at this as at
some point
you're going to be responsible for your
mom's extended care
at some point you're gonna be
responsible for your little brother
um and so i'm gonna start leveling up
and what leveling up means is i'm gonna
take
go out to lunch i'm gonna pay and i'm
gonna take her out to lunch and
first and foremost say thank you so much
for taking care of my family
you're a saint you are a model for me as
a young man
i want to learn how and why tell me my
mom's history
tell me my dad's history tell me like
what makes my little brother tick
and just listen and learn from her she
sounds like a brilliant wise
compassionate woman
and this is also going to put everybody
on the same page
probably do the same thing with your dad
and start
asking him questions does he have a
special needs trust for
your brother does he have a will some of
those these are just 25 year old
man-to-man conversations now
okay yeah and what you're doing is
you're getting everybody on the same
page
and everybody and you can let everybody
know hey here's my boundaries with mom
she calls me and she's drunk she calls
me she's hot i'm just gonna tell her i
love her but i'm not gonna talk to her
when she's this way i'm gonna hang up
if she shows up my house is drunk she's
not gonna be welcome inside my house
because my wife's here my kids my kids
are here etc or whatever that's gonna
look like for you
and then here's the number four constant
constant reaching out whether that's
text messages
i love you know i if you listen to the
show at all i love the handwritten
letter
every week i'm going to sit down this is
for this is for you but ends up being
for her every week you take 30 minutes
to an hour and write her a letter
it could be one page two page on
notebook paper with the lines on it
um and let her know how your week was
let her know that you miss her hope
she's doing great
but these letters over time it
will slowly and i'm talking like a drip
like trying to fill up a swimming pool
with with a tiny little drip
it's going to slowly reconnect with her
it's going to give her a part of her
heart and her mind this relationship
safe this relationship's safe
it could also spiral her into shame and
all that that's her situation not yours
but i want you to have a i want you to
look up in five years
and what's that what's five times 50 i
wanted her holding 250 letters from her
son
they just say pretty much some variation
of this week was a hard week this was a
good week i met a girl
my wife marriage is doing good whatever
your life situation is we're having a
baby
and i want you to know i love you and i
hope you're doing well right
if you can set up once a week or once
every two weeks hey we're gonna meet for
breakfast at cracker barrel
at nine o'clock i'm paying here's the
thing sometimes she's gonna show up
drunk
sometimes she's not gonna show up at all
and it's gonna hurt over and over again
but part of this is you healing too and
all you can heal is you
and you heal through connection so i'm
gonna keep reaching out i'm gonna keep
reaching out i'm gonna keep reaching out
okay
don't take it personal when she doesn't
show up don't take it like oh my mom
hates me
she doesn't she's just not well right
she's really struggling
um and then just know this i've done
this man
not with my mom but i've i've had
relationships with addicts
it's just heartbreaking and so you've
got to take care of yourself making sure
you're eating well making sure you're
taking care of stuff
there's a part of your body and brain
and heart
that is going to need connection too
dude because your mom wasn't there for
you
for a long long time right
can i ask you this do you have what are
your addictive
mechanisms what are your numbing
behaviors um
that's a good question um you've got
them what are they
yeah all right definitely
there's um i've learned this especially
this year about myself
is my wife is the first one to point it
out which is awesome
and not awesome at the same time i was
just about to say
awesome not awesome yeah
um yeah i i am the 10
i'm man flee from conflict
yep um he's like my middle name and so
okay what that looks like is just like
any hard thing i'm just how can i
put every single little thing into my
schedule yeah so that i don't have
a single second to think about a hard
thing there you go
and your schedule can become an
addiction because it's your
heart and mind and brain's way of trying
to control everything because you lived
in chaos
right and here's the thing it will move
from your schedule to something else to
something else and it will just expand
on you
and so learning how to do relational
conflict now
relational conflict in the past got you
hurt right i got you beat up i got you
set on fire it got you
your mom took off on you or whatever
that's a
corner it's like air you got to learn
how to do conflict for your marriage for
your kids
and so i mean i can't recommend enough
that you go see somebody go see him with
your wife
right and she sounds like an awesome
awesome woman awesome partner for you
go see somebody um and let them know i
grew up in the home of an alcoholic i
grew up in a home of with divorce i grew
up with a special needs little brother
um i got a lot to unpack and i got some
skills i need to learn
i need to learn conflict i need to learn
what love looks like because i didn't
see it growing up
i need to learn how to practice how to
have hard conversations because i got a
lot of those ahead of me
um and then you and your wife are gonna
have to just understand probably we're
gonna be taking care of my little
brother
and have him around a lot have him a
part of the life of your life
whatever that looks like for y'all but
yeah you're at that 25 h
and that's when things get hard so i've
given you a lot here i'm not going to
recap at all brother
i want you to know this i'm grateful for
your heart man
it's a heartbreaking call when a when a
son calls me and says man how do i love
my mom and when my mom doesn't even love
herself
it's hard and it's got to keep showing
up and got to keep showing up
listen to this episode do it listen to
it with your wife
y'all come up with a game plan on what
this is going to look like for y'all
what boundaries and compassionate
boundaries are going to look like
what firm boundaries can look like take
the folks out to dinner that you need to
take them out
get get your will get special needs
stuff taken care of
and you're in it for a long haul brother
but i want you to know there's healing
and laughter and joy on the other end of
this deal
and i'm proud of you for being willing
to do the work you're awesome man